he's whacking it
gentle gentle
slow motion
[Music]
so taika is over here experimenting with
all the weapons
who are you gonna snack
who are you gonna smack huh i'm a good
guy you're the bad guy oh you're just
like the bad guy okay okay yeah i was
about to put put put put [ __ ]
[Music]
all right and the reason why we're in
the kitchen because we're literally
almost never in the kitchen okay not we
i
because i'm watching papa cook
we
haven't made steaks
at this house in a long time i think
we've been just trying to get our
schedule together so we finally went to
the store bought some steaks got some
t-bones some bone-in action right here
that's not people what is this
phone in new york maybe phone in ribeye
it's not a rib eye
but anyways
i am kind of rusty but they turn out it
looks pretty good right
yeah it's super cool
[Music]
oh man this is so bomb i would have
cooked it out on the grill because
that's my favorite
but you know the daylight anti-daylight
savings time now what does it cost uh i
think it is daylight savings time but is
it
what's the opposite anti-daily
it's not anti it's uh daylight saving
time and then
daylight wasting time
so it's daylight wasting time now and
it's like four or five and again are
they just both daylight savings well you
can't save twice
because one comes on one comes off
oh watch out oh my god
no okay time out this is this is a real
life
kitchen dude
[Applause]
what was that all that camera action
about sometimes i just want to
experiment all right so while i made
some gourmet steaks why don't you cover
the gourmet vegetables you're making
yeah that came out of a plastic bag
yeah so it's really cool you guys if you
guys do want to do very little to no
work you just go to costco you go to the
frozen section and you get yourself some
vegetables
and here they are
about to boil baby
you ready for my yummy vegetables yeah
tell me i added some extra secret
ingredients to it
i've got a timer when you pull the
stakes off the grill or pan always let
it rest because you see all these juices
it's going to absorb it back in
so i'm setting a little five minute
timer
you're boring you're pulling my bear
what's up that behind you is way more
fun
okay wait and she messed up so now i
gotta eat our instant rice all right
wait and you know what's funny no no
wait wait wait wait and you know what's
funny when we're at the market i was
like hey babe we should get some
instruments like yeah i don't like
instant weights don't get them i trust
me they're so helpful now you know
what damn
okay so he's you're half right you're
half right
he's the most interesting person in this
house for sure
oh my god yeah get your dad please he
talks way too much [ __ ] okay and my
explanation here for the rice i want to
explain to you guys okay
this rice
is old and i don't know i didn't grow up
with white rice like this like this
style of rice growing up i just said i
didn't grow up with this style of rice
growing up yes um
so i'm just not aware okay wait i take
that back
um it's actually i didn't [ __ ] cook
so i didn't even know if this even
happens with just rice in general that's
the statement i wanted to say um
but okay so i have my rice in these
little uh glass jars so clear that you
can see what's going on in here and i
noticed that when the rice gets old and
again i don't know if it's because it's
older if it just comes this way but i'm
assuming that when it gets old
um it starts developing like these
little tiny bugs i don't think you're
gonna be able to see but it's literally
on the oh it just moved it was on the
tip of my right above my finger
and it has these little buggy bugs
there's even one right there
and yeah i'm just not about that so i'm
gonna toss this
because i need no bugs
i thought i heard something
you want to fix your pet leg okay okay
i'll shut up
i mean oh my god
see
let's go together again
where is
he watch out put your back against the
wall put your back against the wall so
he doesn't see you like that
yeah and now you peek peek
peek right here peek peek peek
no no no
like this you're gonna go like this
whoa he's under the table
all right so my gourmet rice is getting
done
okay jokes aside this [ __ ] is really
convenient i'll give it to you you were
right on this one okay i'll give it to
you i told you i'll give it to you hey
this doesn't happen very often hey i
gotta let me represent my korean roots
what
you're 3.03
no my three percent
but uh i'm pretty rusty on this
so i'm kind of scared i don't know i
don't know if it's heard about what this
might be might be well done who cares it
might be medium rare i mean like rare
rare who cares let's test in the middle
okay
it'll be fine
not bad not my best but not bad hey it's
been a minute since we did it
i know
that's not true what that's not true
that's been a minute since we did it
yeah cause we [ __ ] all the time
[Music]
so i'm fixing taika's little truck here
because i guess this bottom keeps
falling off
and besides that
um the batteries also died on it so the
funny thing is i would have been done a
minute ago
but taika every time i walk away from it
to either like look at my gourmet
vegetables or my rice
go check on it look my rice is calling
me
um he'll come over here he turns it on
and then he has the remote control so
then the wheels are just spinning out of
control and i can't fix it that's his
way of getting her attention
i think that's just him tricking me and
being funny that's a kidney
this looks
really bad
but at least the cover's gonna stay on i
hope
all right monkey dude i just went to my
neighbor's house
i feel like the ass cats
or dusty dogs
or something
does that work now mister
hey
i'm just trying to run this over
i don't even know where he is
there's the sneaky snake
did you ever get into cars
i loved it but my parents never bought
one for me
my neighbor had a gasoline one it was so
sick you'd put gasoline my neighbor
anybody that was so loud it would be in
the middle of the street was so fun and
all my other neighbors started getting
into them and they would jump the curbs
and all that and my parents never got
money because it was so expensive
i don't even know we didn't even go look
you just looked expensive because
gasoline ones sound like they're gonna
be expensive yeah cause they're like the
legit race ones yeah i never got into it
but even the electric ones that are
really fast with the felt tires i mean i
felt like uh like foam tires those are
really good boom tires yeah the good
good ones are like foam tires because
they're like uh it has to stick to the
concrete
attack of the
yeah like the legit ones you can't buy
at a toy store you have to go to like a
hobby store
yeah
so we got tyka's dinner haha i still see
it
and
this is the final product not too bad
this literally took like less than 10
minutes to make
obviously this one i think just about 10
minutes and then if you consider the
five minutes you have to let it sweat it
out so like 15 minutes so total 15
minutes not too bad how is it is it
yummy
no oh
don't tell papa
how could you monkey
oh no
you've shattered his heart i'm going
back to california
do you think he's being serious
attack
your check
you should just lock the door so it
doesn't come back inside
no i'm gonna go have dinner
i'll make another one
papa i see what you're doing
hey you don't keep saying that so me oh
monkey we're not playing anymore dude
now you're just being mean yeah now
you're me what if you make me something
i say it's yucky that's so mean
i want you to go
out my house
what you're crazy okay
ponzu
ponzu
let's see if it's good i haven't had
this in a long time
how long wait what's going on it's like
you haven't had it in like 10 years
that's not bad it's not bad at all or we
get this like at bonds or something yeah
i think it's a bone in new york
my nose sounds stuffy it does it's cute
it's cute
i like it what about my gourmet rice and
veggies
right yeah those are some heirloom
carrots i opened the bag myself
tastes like uh i hand picked it for you
from the bag from the farms of
frigidaire
yeah frizz it freeze it air yeah it's
really good yeah
thank you
okay
so monkey what do you got here
yeah so i think it's an advent i don't
think i'm saying that right
um but basically a countdown calendar
yes so every day
you open one up and inside is a surprise
so what day are you opening today
inside it's
a lot of traffic inside this box there's
a lot of chocolates
okay open it wait that's not the right
date what day was that
oh no
all right monkey there are no cupcakes
here
are you sure
let me see
i see it hey there's no cupcakes in here
do you see it let me see if you see it
there's no drinks in here are you sure
are you sure let me see there's open
stuff i think there's good stuff go go
oh what
i know he ate everything
here
[Music]
now what's happening
you know me i don't like to waste food
but this was frozen i think it's going
to be okay no it's it's it's there's an
expiration type of type of like
half-life deal it's a biology thing
okay i was saying that we shouldn't
encourage people to get coffee lovers
alive because it's that good it was
really good yeah don't get it guys do
not get coffee lovers delight
oh thank you okay sure
tell us about your give me cupcake look
at that cookie
oh okay
is that it
what else you got
oh man
i don't know if you're gonna do good in
a vlogging career
okay let me see
i'm gonna do tacos vlogging techniques
can you vlog me
oh god you look so scary i don't want to
see it no
i'm doing these techniques
oh come here eyes are so red cause i've
been sniffing dogs all day
i knew your wrath was going to be open
[Laughter]
something i'm super proud of taika
is his ability to clean up and even the
teachers at school says he does a really
good job when it's time to put
everything away that's when it's time
what hey you're not supposed to peek
over there
those are all for him
i said none of those are oh none of them
are him oh okay
it's for his family huh yeah he half of
those he paid for or okay wait he paid
for what
with his charming good luck with kid
coin
put it back that's not yours
okay can we clean up please i was
literally telling everyone how good you
are cleaning up and then you're just
messing around now
come on duty duty come on spider-man
so spider-man
has a hard stomach huh
you brought all your night toys
cuny guy
got your pajamas diaper spiderman
[Music]
you got two blankies now
oh my god are you kidding me i did it
get ready to take a shower okay okay
what under the stomach
whoa you moved hey
you got skills dude
watch this
so i was about to get this dude dressed
and he told me he could do it himself
should i believe him let me see
let's see if you can do it
okay
all right that's the top
let's see
i feel like i'm watching a monkey figure
out how to open up a box
you are
you are
this monkey is very very smart
not that smart it's been like 30 seconds
it's been 30 seconds just discovered he
even has hands like not too long ago
okay
let's see backwards i keep getting down
there you go hey no cheating no cheating
no notes
let's see
let's see if he does it again
whoa whoa whoa
hey that's a breakthrough right there
there you go
wow baby show them what you got baby
show them what you got
good job
okay
there you go that's really good
and everything i know yeah
i'm very impressed mister
okay there goes one leg
because usually i see two legs in one
pant leg we'll see
oh he's doing it
didn't pretty good so far
stop dude
the tag might be in the wrong place
yeah that's pretty good
good job high five
that was awesome
okay
[Music]
do you see that about your heart
so he said that and then um oh man what
was the new one he just said
darn
i lost it
our craft can make my heart crack that
was yeah that's the one
and then there was another one that you
just did that was so cool
what
he's also intrigued
i forgot darn forget about it
um
this is super cuny it became another one
of our many many traditions here at
the freaking bail cave um we have papa
reading to tyga every night
in here
start your day
what you wear when you play
or if you come from far away
right here ty which one's you which
one's your monkey
yeah
hey you're wearing red right now too
no
wait what's wrong with this there's
nothing wrong with this she's praying
yeah
what are they playing over there soccer
soccer
baby
because they're so dang cute gather now
let's all take paul oh
the gita
oh wait the action's coming back
here
where's psycho
there he is yeah that looks like a thai
guy i've literally seen him do this in
jiu jitsu
every
night time for lunch what a spread
you wouldn't what the
you wouldn't believe
what we're about to watch
you guys wouldn't believe what we're
about to watch
it's night time
it's our routinely
it's our routine to watch this
every night
how many times have you seen it as a kid
would you say
i've definitely seen it more with him
than i have as a kid oh damn here we go
of course
of course
we've seen this
literally a hundred times
a hundred times monkey
a hundred times
damn so this is really what your late
thirties look like hobbit
look at this
and what do you mean by that man
that's one
and then check out his back what do you
mean by that look at this
you're just a freaking
dumpster fire right now why
because you can't breathe your back's
jacked up you're just an old man
sometimes in the middle of the night i
wake up and i feel like i'm like my
mouth is dry and i realize my nose is
clogged and my mouth is open
so i'm trying to not do that i see
what exactly does a stem machine do
which is this guy right here feels good
cool there you go science
did it go on it like contracts the
muscles right
technically it stimulates the muscle
um
and it helps contract it and also builds
neural pathways
and by it contracting when you have
knots
uh because you have actin and myosin
channels it opens up and it allows uh
sodium and potassium and calcium ions to
pass through and then when it's a knot
that's not happening
so by putting this on it should be
breaking it apart hopefully
huh
yeah like he said
it just feels good
see how hot there it is
feels good
hey don't enjoy it too much
no hey
stop
get away from me it feels good get away
from him [ __ ]
i don't need you no more thank god
okay
just did the stem machine
no idea if it did any work or not
um but i'll see you tomorrow
and mama bear asked me if i could put it
on her
so i guess i'll put it on her
oh what's with the weird positive nope
nope nope nope
so you guys know what i'm talking about
see you guys tomorrow good night